spectacular superstar in the NBA he's
got star written all over him really
superstar written all over not just lo I
have to love the fact that he's just
such a good teammate man so humble
you could tell that he was raised right
to parents in his home that obviously
discipline was involved in that he said
his mom is the toughest coach how about
that he is with Maria Taylor now Maria
well Zion certainly the moment we all
anticipated but you've been waiting for
this moment since you were five how
would you describe being the number one
overall pick from this track I mean I
don't know what to say I didn't think
I'd be in this position
my mom's like a right slot for me I
wouldn't be able on my mom she didn't
she did everything for me I just want to
thank her
your mom was your coach when you were
coming up she coached you until you were
14 what are the sacrifices you feel as
though she made for you
she put Chico her dreams aside for mine
she always like she obviously done for
the family friends would worry so
mom we can see that Sion visibly
emotional as are you what are you
feeling right now in this moment we work
these work just five for this moment and
when you know was coming but you just
can't really just gotta wait for it to
happen and so watch his hard work pay
off and to watch this we're still happy
for him but we're so happy mom what have
you seen from your son over the course
of this entire process I've seen
somebody who believed in the process we
put in the work and who you know put
those naysayers aside and just continue
to do what we asked and continue to
believe in the process and because of
that we're here today in Zion I know you
said you didn't believe that you would
be here in this moment when did that
belief change was it shaking the
commissioners hand and officially being
the pick yeah I don't even see the road
I just shake his hand I dreamed about
this since I was four and four I'd
actually happen I just thank God for